- Alright y'all, close with
one last delicious dish,
a cherry on top of this tasty hour.
I'm excited.
This is what I'm liking.
(introductory music sting)
- So all hour I've had
the chance to be a curious
and active student at
Iron Chef University.
Thanks to the cast of
the new Netflix series.
Iron Chef: Quest for an Iron Legend.
(crowd cheering)
- We have baked.
We have fried.
We have learned, we have
sip cocktails and dined.
It has been awesome.
Sorry that you only got to watch.
Now, it's time for dessert
though, with Gabriela Camara.
Give it up!
(crowd cheers)
What are we making ma'am?
- Okay. Since we had
to make a fast dessert
and desserts are not easy to make fast
because usually desserts
take a longer time
to make, bake-
- [Kelly] You're used to a challenge.
- Yes. So this is something
that I used to really enjoy
when I was growing up.
- Okay.
- It's very easy.
You know a quesadilla, right? Have you-
- [Kelly] Love quesadillas.
- [Gabriela] Right? Okay.
So this is, you know, corn in Mexico.
I'm from Mexico.
Corn is our basic food.
So here we have two tortillas.
Okay. And we have delicious toma cheese.
It's already been prepared for us.
- And I have never even seen anything
that looks like this. Wow.
- I know this is a big one.
I actually do not possess one this size.
- I feel very fancy
having this in my hand.
- And then you take out the top part.
- Yeah. Okay.
- This is really, mm.
- I've got it.
- And now what we're gonna do
is we're gonna put quince paste.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- You could also put just some,
some people just put sugar.
- Fine.
- [Gabriela] Chocolate, Nutella.
So then we cover this.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- And just to make it more
desserty, we're gonna put cajeta.
So we're going, put it
over our quesadilla.
- Quesadilla.
- And now what we're
gonna do is we're gonna do
again confessioners sugar.
We like that.
- I do
- Just for beauty
because this isn't a
very beautiful dessert.
Look at this. Look at this technique.
Look at this.
- Oh, I just learned your technique.
Oh it's small.
I did too much.
Okay, okay, okay.
- [Gabriela] It's fine.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- And then you just cut it and however-
- [Kelly] It's like a pizza.
I like it.
- Pizza, pizza.
- [Kelly] Okay. Okay.
Are y'all enjoying yours over there?
- Oh it's so good.
- [Gabriela] Is it good?
- Yeah.
- [Gabriela] This really
a childhood memory.
- It's not delicious.
It's delicioso.
- Delicioso!
- [Chef] Muy sabrosa.
- [Gabriela] Muy sabroso.
- [Chef] I love coat on top-
- I love our Spanish
lesson sneaking in here.
- Wait, so now I wanna taste it.
I've already cut my-
Look, I'm like fast.
- [Gabriela] Okay, go.
- [Kelly] You have food on a table.
I'm gonna cut it up.
I'm gonna eat it.
- [Gabriela] Okay. Okay.
Ready?
- Yes. Okay.
Oh, hold it.
Oh, oh my God.
That's so good.
(applause)
Okay. I'm definitely
liking this right now.
It's so delicious.
Please have it sent to my room.
This is the part in the
show where usually we'd
give our guests a thousand dollars
courtesy of our season long partner,
Pilot Pin, makers of G2, the go-to pin
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show".
But today they got money.
So we're giving it to a charity.
All our guests support, No Kid Hungry.
(applause)
Thank you to everyone who
joined in the show this hour:
Curtis Stone, Ming Tsai, Dominique Crenn,
Marcus Samuelsson, Gabriela
Camara, and Sahana.
Y'all have a great day.
And if it's not, make something like this.
It will turn your life around.